[Music]
in move [ __ ] news Oh throwing away the
way get out the way [ __ ] get out the
way something by Silvia loves JK ha yeah
boo - Sophia hey woman stole a parking
space by standing in the middle and
refusing to budge oh you know that's
illegals I found out
yeah what why I was doing that one time
remember it was like Maine and Garfield
and I was trying to hold the the spot
for her and then this guy comes with his
car and then uh she was like even trying
to circle back and he was like honking
at me and I'm like I move it and then he
gets out of the car like we're about to
fight and then uh I was office
[ __ ] gonna fight for a parking
space I'll have a better throw down and
you go so you need to move I'm like I'm
not gonna move up though I'm saving this
parking space and he goes to still legal
and I thought it was just being like a
dick you know I was i well I'm not
moving he goes I'm a police officer and
shown his badge because I'm off-duty and
it is illegal I'm like okay I'm very
sorry
wow you got school I got school but you
know it was cool he's super nice he goes
but so let you have the space he drove
off what yeah he's super nice he didn't
[ __ ] like I think he's gonna buse his
power I thought he was but he was a
super nice guy just in regular civilian
clothes and see I didn't know that if it
was illegal and where this happened and
it is so I didn't know it was illegal
but I know it's an [ __ ] move in space
idea I thought I was just like playing
like a tag-team wrestling I was I was at
IKEA and this dude like I literally was
this guy just stood there right and then
you know people are getting pissed but
you know I'm not a little punk [ __ ] so
I literally got a mate how does like a
mate you got it's only gonna take like
two minutes people are just loading
things like get out yeah yeah and then
literally got this point is goes well he
said well are you gonna help me move and
I looked at him got so [ __ ] mad cuz
the way he talked to my guess I guess
yeah and I walked out and I got so
[ __ ] infuriated I don't know why I
did this but I just rolled up to Maz
like what the [ __ ] and then like he
employed him and they kicked him out man
it was like yo come on man
like and you know everybody else is so
non-confrontational but it's not okay
because it just takes two minutes and
move and you'll get your spot if you
just wrap around it's like what the [ __ ]
dude an Ikea man that's like going into
a war zone
yeah do when you're going to park there
and pick up your [ __ ] especially the
Burbank wonder bag they're more
civilized a pair you're out of your mind
in a shopping center your honor you have
to like do this crosswalk [ __ ] yup
the Westco if you know what it's all
built-in yeah it's its own standalone
building burping is that you park here
you go buy it then you go get your car
from the parking lot and then you bring
it you wanna know something very
interesting to people are a lot smaller
from a distance so I walked up to him I
was like this guy's gonna [ __ ] me up
luckily that IKEA guy saved me like
there's old like [ __ ] German oh damn
something that German Swit Swedish dude
from the front that kicked him out oh
there he imported him he [ __ ] say no
there's a the one at the Berbick one
there's a there's an old Swedish man
there IKEA got him yeah I got you I got
you
he is in the mr. IKEA yeah yeah you know
mr. IKEA IKEA yeah is your family name
IKEA no I don't think so Bobby times a
Swedish guy and I saw a picture of him
on Forbes mr. IKEA is he like bees those
jacks cuz you know he's old bad you got
jack [ __ ] Jeff Bezos is [ __ ] bill you
should see it before and after pictures
oh dude before and afters hilarious he
looks like he doesn't really be so's
bessel you Jesus yeah oh it's not
business I just save those it's not is
it
what I don't know have you seen him
before
sounds like a PEZ those two you know he
looks like a B Zoe's there's only one
ito
what is he is he is he Mexican alright
like this parking spot story this took
place in New York and it is illegal in
New York to send in a preface as well as
California is just yep know every state
has their own so what I know that now
alright I want to just won't let out my
window to people doing this is I used to
go this is illegal okay I can't wait to
be the dweeb that says that I know it's
the worst I can never say it out loud no
way yeah I used to do it but now I'm
just like man I would love somebody told
me it's legal what's the charge man
throw the book at me pal I'm talking
hold this for my wife what do you want
me to do
the rest [ __ ] yeah right you
know what else is illegal loitering
but whoever gets in trouble for lawyers
jaywalking guess what that's how you get
by in LA give me a break
you know if the lawyer is truly illegal
there'd be a lot of ages in jail because
that's all we do yeah that's like our
pastime that's how we create a JK news
hey y'all want to go loiter tomorrow all
right cool I love that everybody calls
the loitering hey we're going loading
really later right 7:30 yep let's loiter
guys all right so I'm gonna show you
guys the dashcam footage of this entire
interaction are you kidding
you're not even in a car woman woman are
you kidding you're not in the car
get out where I don't see no car you
just run into a spot right now are you
serious are you serious right now woman
serious woman I like the caller this is
a car parking spot not a woman parking
guy is such a this is why I won't say it
oh [ __ ] hey I got time
why did it have to why do they have to
be our people it's our thing I bet you
the Chinese another spot walk into it
and let your dad take it I'm already
here how can we sounds like Anthony Lee
into the spy that is Anthony I'm not
being too proud which car you in which
car you in that's true dainties that's
way gangster yeah just run the run over
the low wage low creep slowly just just
pass it's really a loose situation for
people though both sides yeah it's so
petty but if you go what if you go me
you just start pumping them you're like
I might continue yeah and you just like
move them I'm not better than petty
because this wannabe right so bad but I
feel like there's more stress in New
York for Park mark baby for sure yeah
this was in Flushing Queens I feel like
they they probably circled around for
the last 40 minutes and they finally got
a spot that's why you need that old IKEA
guy he would [ __ ] his shoe then the [ __ ]
away
I didn't the ladies do that dogs it's
probably okay in Asia
oh no but they were asian-american
though they don't have an accent but
they might not even know the rules like
me where I was just that way why can't I
why can't why can't I save a parking you
knew it was illegal
it doesn't matter leave the [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah I think it's a big thing to
do yeah I thought I was being a good
friend
no I that's dick move because it's
always first-come first-serve oh it's
not you're right it's basically like
cutting in line and saving the spot for
your friends which we do all the time
yeah but it is it's technically a dick
move let me let me make it more dick so
it's like saving this spot for ten
friends and it's a limited kind of Lube
your factory okay it's like limited
Jordan's you only get five brought like
your five friends before and you were
second in line and they were waiting
it's like that
I love that Bart is just a dick he
doesn't know no I didn't know cuz I'm
like what the same you are the same he's
like if you walk to the front of the
line and nobody stops you then that's
great well on the flip side though it's
make Bart likkle bit better if someone
did that to him you wouldn't trip I
wouldn't be like oh that's right it's
just the people in the car like tag-team
if somebody could align harm you if
someone cuts Ally in front of me at the
movie theater I really give a [ __ ] I'm
like you're just saving it for your
homie right cool I would've done the
same for me it depends so somebody
saving a spot for people like that was
already there it's cool but if I sees
like 10 people nah that's not happening
yeah if it's 10 people on my hey that's
kind of [ __ ] up okay so my friend is
like I don't give up [ __ ] I'd be like
yeah go ahead
I'll get my ass beat by all of you
I see Plus Ones all the time it's that
guy holding spot for his girlfriend or
girlfriend on the spot yeah cuz she went
to go get P or bi yeah they're already
in line together already
you don't mean or if it's like one
person that I don't give a [ __ ] but if
it's like a group of people yeah and
then it's a different story so for me
like in the parking space because it's I
assume those two ladies came in the car
like all five of them came in the car
I'm like oh they're all part of the same
car so they just you know parking space
couple years ago I was in a movie we're
seeing a social network right and so
Peter was packed everyone seen this
[ __ ] movie and we got there and we're
saving the seat for my girlfriend
and I was like me and my buddy and his
wife and my it was gonna be my
girlfriend to me
and we're waiting for my girlfriend I
get there and so we have three seats
reserved well those seats the right of
me this couple comes and the guy like
takes the seat or whatever he's like I'm
checking to see now and again oh man
this is for my girlfriend whatever he's
just [ __ ] sit sit did you put the
jacket there yeah all of it yeah and he
just did it anyway
Wow dick move its to the extreme so you
really want to sit that bad next yeah
right exactly so so that was just a
packed house there's packed houses
[ __ ] he's like oh she's not here man
is no cooling out here not here and then
when the movie was over my dude my buddy
who's who was from like [ __ ] Boston
he's like a [ __ ] one of these guys
who's like got a circumstellar he was
like a former target security guard
he got it he got a you know lay down the
law sale a time law yes movie and yeah
like I'm talking like it's like the
social network directed like written by
Aaron Sorkin my friends like hey man
I got a quick question industry like
immediately like with all of his might
that's sitting next to him or he had a
cross over you he had a cross over me so
he was punching him friendly firing me
you know what that means well your
friend did not watch that whole movie no
he was saying the whole time he's like
[ __ ] yeah the whole time well hold
you plotting what to do and then my
friends [ __ ] it awesome and then my
friend like [ __ ] runs like like he
had just assassinated the Abraham
Lincoln in the movie so he just bails on
you [ __ ] like jumps on top of the
chair he steps on a four-year-old and
then his wife I'm with his wife in the
cat's like go to [ __ ] man the [ __ ]
look your those you guy whatever man and
the guy spits on his [ __ ] wife oh I
mean everyone starts working like oh you
know it was crazy and then my friends
like you heard this Betty [ __ ] ran
back there no no no so hilarious that he
just bailed on you guys bailed he bailed
too I would have done the same though
Warren you got right with the best [ __ ]
right so the best thing is but the
craziest guy has to keep the best thing
is this guy this guy like took [ __ ] so
seriously cuz use a target security guy
and he was like I'm a security
professional okay so he he calls his
wife right
and he's like Kim like we got a 76 or
whatever I swear to god he's like we
have a 76 and she's like Andy what the
[ __ ] you talking about what is the
[ __ ] 76 and he was like no he's like
a kid who's the [ __ ] 76 right now
because he had this code system so he
thought with his wife where if she was
like say with a police officer he could
say some [ __ ] and she would be like oh
hey mom yeah sorry gotta go but she
didn't know the
and do you beat the living [ __ ] out of
so this badass like he [ __ ] fleas is
why I can't spin on it that he calls her
and he's like you know we got a we got a
[ __ ] 24 and she's like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about eighty Andy I
can't hear what you're talking about or
what you know and then the dude just so
we then then we ended up going we had to
go find him because he was hiding in a
bush or something to pick him up with a
car but she was [ __ ] hilarious how
[ __ ] awesome in his world
all he had to say is 24b and his wife's
like absolutely hundred-percent like
she's you know but night not happening
yeah yeah no one's in the world with him
oh yeah it was great
I always loved having that one homey
that you know if things are getting to
that brink they're gonna cross that line
and just beat the [ __ ] out of some I
hate that he didn't like I told this one
it's like literally I run this guy he
used to always pick fights but he'd
literally no joke but he has his habit
of staring at people and he wonders why
people are staring at him right there
wondering why you're looking at that
yeah you know what I mean yeah oh God
[Music]